[Music]
a community support service on a
double-decker bus set up by the local
secondary school
the aim to help struggling families with
food health care and advice an attempt
to reconnect their children with an
education system many have dropped out
of
covert hit two years of being locked in
his bedroom he's basically he won't go
anywhere
he's his anxiety he's gone through the
roof well i'm worried about his mental
health now stefan's here to collect
groceries from the social supermarket
with his two-year-old grandson but his
16 year old son hasn't gone back to
school at all since lockdown it's
horrendous to see somebody like that you
hear about it more than older people but
younger children no it's not just one or
two there's hundreds of thousands of
children out there now that
aren't getting the help i believe they
now need stefan's son is far from alone
according to the latest report from the
children's commissioner the number of
severely absent pupils who missed at
least 50 per cent of school reached 124
000 last year and 1.8 million were
persistently absent missing 10 percent
these have been dubbed england's ghost
children
champion kent is one of the most
deprived parts of the country at the
island's only secondary school the oasis
academy more than half of the 1500 or so
pupils are regularly choosing not to
come to school that's a persistent
absence rate of 54
before the pandemic that figure was just
13
steve chalk is the founder and head of
the oasis charitable trust which runs
this academy and 51 others the charities
invested 300 000 pounds to kit out the
support bus and hire a team of youth
workers
schools can't be left to make up for all
this on their own schools do a fantastic
job they really do around the country
but they can't be left to make up for
the whole deficit out of a non-existent
budget it just doesn't work
we have to invest now
or we'll inherit a whirlwind and the
whirlwind will be that there will be
many more ghost children and ghost
families as well as family struggles
with poverty and mental health issues
many of the children missing school are
thought to have special educational
needs altogether since the pandemic is
estimated some 40 000 pupils have
disappeared completely from both the
state and independent sector and aren't
being schooled at home either the former
children's commissioner says these young
people are at huge risk
well i'm deeply concerned about these
children um i think what we're seeing is
almost an avalanche of inequalities here
these are children with deep-seated
anxieties sometimes such chronic
anxieties that they can't believe their
home never mind get into the classroom
they may have special educational needs
there may be family issues and the
family needs support to be able to help
those children go into school sell a
whole myriad of issues but what we do
know is that those children are most
vulnerable are likely to be the ones
that are most likely to be out of school
and when children
are missing from school in this way they
are very vulnerable to exploitation
aren't they
what we know is that those adults who
are seeking to find vulnerable children
to exploit them to get them involved in
their gang activities possibly dealing
drugs and exploiting them with county
lines will often relish this prospect of
children not being in school this week
education secretary james cleverley went
to visit donistor primary academy in
derbyshire announcing an attendance
drive for the start of the school year
including new guidance which makes it
clear that schools should be providing
families with support but also issuing
fines were appropriate too it's
estimated around 40 000 children have
completely disappeared from school
registers um since the pandemic neither
in home education nor moved into the
independent sector how is that possible
that that can happen and do you have any
plans to address that we
should all look to do
is have a better understanding of the
sector better understanding of you know
which schools are open when they're open
which young people are at school being
educated now at the moment we don't have
a comprehensive knowledge base it's a
it's a it is a geographically dispersed
sector and that's always been a
challenge when it comes to data
collection but i i know certainly as
secretary of state for education i would
like to have a better idea of which
schools are open
which students are and are not at school
but the conservative chair of the
education select committee who coined
the phrase ghost children says the
government should have done much more
over the past two years
well for two years i've been calling for
a register of
children who are not in school and that
can't happen
soon enough it should have happened ages
ago says that they say it's going to be
in the schools bill it better be and
it's got to
come through very very quickly so at
least then they'll be able to track some
of these
these children of children who are not
in school and that can't happen
soon enough it should have happened ages
ago it says that they say it's going to
be in the schools bill it better be and
it's got to
come through very very quickly for mps
it's back to school next week and a new
prime minister too whether or not mr
cleverley keeps his new role as
education secretary in the resulting
reshuffle getting these lost children
back to the classroom will be a key test
for the government
you